il y a un an le 24 février 2022 Vladimir
Poutine Lancelle l'invasion de l'Ukraine
une date qui marque le lancement des
hostilités et qui va donc pousser de
nombreuses Ukrainiens à quitté leur pays
la rédaction de TV tour a donc décidé de
se mobiliser toute cette semaine pour
faire le point sur ses hommes et ses
femmes qui ont été accueillies chez nous
pour le premier volet de notre série
direction le camping de La
Ville-aux-Dames dès le 15 mars 2022 des
bungalows ont été réservés pour servir
de logement au réfugiés regardez
donc ici oui on est dans un mobil-home
donc quatre chambres qui peuvent
recevoir jusqu'à 8 personnes on est en
train de remettre toute la vaisselle en
place tout est propre le chauffage est
en marche il y a 11 mois le camping de
La Ville-aux-Dames se préparait à
accueillir ses premiers Ukrainiens
l'endroit avait été choisi par la
préfecture pour servir d'accueil
temporaire aujourd'hui sur les 40
mobil-homes que compte le site 29
servent toujours d'hébergement pour les
réfugiés un lieu au calme ou Yuri et
Nadia ont posé leurs bagages depuis
maintenant 9 mois à 68 et 69 ans ce sont
les seniors du camping de prophyla
typique et attendrissant qui ont pris
pour habitude d'aller nourrir les poules
du voisinage
ils ont quitté ni pro car cela devenait
trop compliqué de descendre à pied les 8
étages de leur immeuble à chaque alerte
aux bombardement ils ont laissé derrière
eux leur fils unique son épouse et leur
petit-fils
de nos proches quand on apprend que le
conflit se calme un peu et qu'il n'y a
pas de bombardement c'est aussi quand on
peut entendre les voix de nos proches
c'est notre plus grand bonheur et les
petits bonheurs qui nous font aussi
tenir ce sont les rencontres avec des
gens de La Ville-aux-Dames
quand on va chez eux ou quand on les
accueille chez nous un couple a un bébé
et je peux le prendre dans mes bras je
lui fais des bisous partout sur ses
petits pieds ces petites mains et j'ai
alors l'impression que je retrouve mon
petit-fils
depuis le 15 mars
202274 personnes ont été accueillies au
camping de La Ville-aux-Dames des
réfugiés qui ne parlent évidemment pas
notre langue et qu'il faut t'aider pour
qu'il puisse bénéficier d'une
attestation provisoire de séjour ou
qu'il touche la location demandeur
d'asile c'est le rôle de l'association
en trait des solidarités qui disposent
d'un bureau sur place on a une équipe
donc au sein du service secret de
travailleurs sociaux qui accompagnent
donc plus maintenant sur l'insertion
professionnelle l'apprentissage de la
langue on essaie de travailler sur
l'autonomisation sur la mobilité parce
que la plupart ne sont pas véhiculées
l'accès aux soins aussi est une grosse
priorité aussi puisque c'est des
personnes aussi qui ont des problèmes de
santé la scolarisation on a des enfants
qui sont scolarisés sur le département
en fonction de la du lieu d'habitation
voilà donc c'est vraiment un ensemble
global sur l'accompagnement qu'on peut
leur proposer
au camping 78 des 80 places réservées au
réfugiés Ukrainiens sont aujourd'hui
occupés au Léna et son fils au lycée ils
vivent depuis trois mois cette
psychologue souhaite désormais apprendre
le français pour pouvoir travailler et
rendre ce qu'on lui a offert